un mercredi comme les rentrer à roubaix
à quelques mètres du vélodrome école
désaffectée quarantaine de jeunes de 7 à
14 ans ici au vélo club de roubaix créée
en 1960 en ne badine pas avec la
tradition cette sortie d'entraînement
comme bien souvent se font sur les pavés
des pavés qui sont d'habitude la hantise
des professionnels mais qui
n'impressionne pas outre mesure les
flottilles chimie de la petite reine
ça te fait pas peur du tout fonctionné
cet impressionnant pas ici rien n'est
laissé au hasard
jacques l'heureux 65 ans en connaît un
rayon sur les premiers centres et une
distille ses petits secrets ses élèves
qui malgré les traces hautement de la
machine les quoi religieux
auxerre est allé
c'est à dire c'est ma long c'est vrai
que le soir de retour à la maison ils
sont les cibles et les jeunes fuient
une tête
2 est il écoute
seul un gros pic et courbatures du monde
pour
paris roubaix ça féret ça fait rêver les
jeunes cyclistes et ils ont tous besoin
nature de rêve quand ils entreprennent
un sport et par les robes et c'est
vraiment le rêve hors du commun en plus
un jour peut-être que petit pouvoir
devient très grand tu connaissais la six
ans devait déjà devant sa télé de ces pv
à force de courage printemps 90 l'ariège
grand rêve porter le permis à bout de
bras
e